Let's consider a
gravitational slingshot.
What is that?
Well, once in a while, people
like to send spacecrafts out
into the solar
system, particularly
the outer solar system, to
explore what's going on there.
And because we can't on
Earth give enough speed
to these little spacecrafts, we
need the big planets around us
to help us a little.
And so we can consider a large
planet like Jupiter or Saturn.
Here we have Saturn.
And if we have a
little spacecraft
and we make it fly by close,
then what actually happens
is it will, due to the
gravitational attraction
of Saturn, acquire
a kick in velocity.
And that is a
gravitational slingshot.
So let's look at that.
So our little spacecraft comes
in with an initial velocity.
And Saturn, of course,
also has a velocity.
And once it has passed,
our little spacecraft
will have a final velocity.
And in order to calculate what
this final velocity is going
to be, what the increase
in speed is going to be,
we need the concept
of relative velocity.
And for that, we need to first
consider some initial state.
So we have the relative
velocity initially.
And that is the difference
between those two velocities,
between the
spacecraft and Saturn.
And what becomes
very important here
is that we look at
the coordinate system.
And keep that in mind.
Otherwise, we're going
to get a few sign errors.
So the initial velocity
of the spacecraft
goes in the i hat direction.
And the velocity--
the relative velocity
is, of course,
the difference, so
minus the velocity of Saturn.
But that one goes in the
minus i hat direction.
And then we have
the final state.
So V final relative.
And here we have
the final velocity
of the spacecraft now
going in the minus i hat
direction minus the
velocity of Saturn
that also goes in the
minus i hat direction.
Now, there is one thing
that we need to consider,
which is this
velocity of Saturn.
This one actually
is, of course, here,
the initial velocity of Saturn,
and this one is the final one.
But because the
mass of Saturn is
much larger than the
mass of the spacecraft,
we can actually set the
initial velocity of Saturn
to the final velocity of Saturn.
So we can turn this-- we can
take this away here again,
and just consider one
velocity of Saturn.
OK, good.
There's one more thing that we
need in order to solve this,
because we need to know how
the relative velocities are
actually related.
And the energy momentum
law helps us there,
because that gives us that
the initial relative velocity
equals minus the final
relative velocity.
OK, so we can plug that in now.
What do we have here for
the initial velocity?
We have Vi minus two i's gives
us a plus the Saturn velocity.
And that equals--
minus minus gives us a
plus-- the final velocity
of the spacecraft.
And then we have
three minuses here,
so that gives us a minus
the Saturn velocity.
And we know from the problem
that the initial velocity here
of the spacecraft
was actually given
at three Saturn velocities.
So we can tally this up now.
We have three-- we have
three plus one is four.
And we'll put this
over on the other side.
That gives us five.
Five Saturn velocities
equals our final velocity.
So that's quite a good
gain, I would say.
And it nicely illustrates
why big planets like Jupiter
and Saturn are really, really
helpful for the exploration
of the solar system.
And that is actually how the
New Horizons mission made it out
to Pluto, all the way out there.